قبل أربع سنوات فقط ، خطت نصف دزينة
من الفتيات الأفغانيات بثقة في
المنافسة يلوحن بعلم
بلادهن ، كانت المنافسة العالمية للروبوتات التي أقيمت
في الولايات المتحدة فرصة لإظهار ما
شكك الكثيرون في بلدهم في أن الفتيات
يمكنهن تحقيق أي
شيء وإنجازهن بفوزهن بجائزة
لاقتباس الإنجاز الشجاع
الممنوح للفرق التي ثابرت في
ظروف صعبة ،
فقد تغير الكثير منذ ذلك الحين
في غضون أشهر من هذا العام ،
اجتاحت طالبان أفغانستان
وأسقطت مدينة تلو الأخرى ، مما شكل تهديدًا مميتًا
للفتيات مثل أولئك في فريق الروبوتات
المثقف التقدمي الدقيق  على
عكس الطريقة التي يعتقد بها طالبان أنه يجب أن
تكون المرأة ، لذا اتخذ خمسة من الفريق الأصلي
قرار الفرار في رحلة مروعة
ذهبوا من هرات أفغانستان
إلى كابول هناك وتمكنوا من ركوب
واحدة من آخر الرحلات الجوية التجارية
قبل أن يأخذ طالبان المدينة  من
هناك تلاها إسلام أباد باكستان في
نهاية المطاف ثم الدوحة قطر ثم
فرانكفور  ألمانيا ثم إلى مدينة المكسيك
في العاصمة المكسيكية حيث
سمحت لهم الحكومة هنا بالبقاء
بينما يكتشفون ما هو التالي
هنا في المدينة حيث حصلنا على فرصة
للقاء شخصيًا
بأمان في المكسيك.
الوطن
ووحشية نظام طالبان
، حكم حكومتهم مجرد
استهزاء وإهانة للإسلام ، بينما الإسلام
هو دين اللطف ،
نطلب التفضل ليس فقط من الولايات المتحدة
ولكن من
المجتمع الدولي بأسره للقضاء على
جيل طالبان من أفغانستان وهم يعرفون
ذلك  الولايات المتحدة لديها خيارات محدودة في هذا
الصدد بعد انسحابها ،
وضعًا رهيبًا لأولئك المعارضين
لطالبان ، وهم يعرفون أيضًا كم كانوا
محظوظين بالخروج ، وكان من الصعب حقًا
أن تعلموا
ترك أحبائنا في أفغانستان
ولكننا سعداء لأننا اليوم  آمنون
ليس فقط بسبب أنفسنا ولكن هنا
يمكننا أن نكون صوت آلاف
الفتيات اللواتي يرغبن في
البقاء بأمان في أفغانستان واللاتي يرغبن في
الاستمرار  تعليمهن وتعال
واجعل أحلامهن حقيقة
واقعة متضائلة للفتيات في ذلك
البلد في الأسابيع والأشهر التي تلت
تولي طالبان لأعمالهم اللاحقة ،
وقد أعادت أعمالهم اللاحقة التأكيد على العودة إلى
مجتمع تُعامل فيه النساء على أنهن
غير متساويات تمامًا مع الرجال.
لديه رسالة لأولئك الذين
تركوا وراءهم ،
لذا فإن رسالتي ورسالتي إلى
جيلي
هي أنه من فضلك لا
تفقد الأمل ، روحك
أينما كنت في أفغانستان ، فأنا أعلم أنه من
الصعب لأنني فتاة أفريقية
أيضًا وأنا أفهمك تمامًا  لكن من
فضلك لا تفقد انتشارك ، فهناك
دائمًا
ضوء في ذروة الظلام ، فقط
اجعل حلمك واتبع
حلمك واعتقد أنه يومًا ما سوف
يتحقق حلمك لأنني جربت
ذلك وسألنا جميع الفتيات ماذا
تريد  للقيام بعد ذلك في المستقبل القريب
وفي المستقبل الطويل ،
تخبرنا جميع الفتيات الأربع اللائي تحدثنا عنهن أنهن
يخططن للذهاب إلى الكلية في مكان ما
في الولايات المتحدة على أمل أن يقولوا
ذلك  المستقبل على المدى الطويل
يأملون جميعًا في العودة إلى أفغانستان
يومًا ما
أنهار مات سي إن إن مكسيكو سيتي